[Applaudissements]
sans plan françois delagnes être
superman
bonjour mon image alors que le psg pieds
noirs qui laisse un peu c'est bien la
fois le cash est simple espagnol qui
laisse c'est le dernier ou est-ce que
vous êtes sensible à cette remontée
disent pas les dalles en ce moment un
peu partout en europe
je suis sensible surtout est comme ça et
que ça me rappelle probablement des
racines très forte et beaucoup que j'ai
beaucoup aimé il sera certes un flamenco
c'est les beatles ne vous agace le plus
votre surnom mauvaise forme google donné
et que j'ai lu ici ou là je trouve que
je trouve très drôle mais qui aurait
cependant la réalité votre sonoco
d'eskhol donc en souvenir de l'agasc
vous aviez fait honneur aux contrats de
valence j'ai regretté gilles trequesser
l'utilisation n'a été fait j'ai écrit ça
dans un livre
à deux ans j'ai écrit en détails parce
que sa seule fois que j'ai écrite mais
regardez comme les choses sont drôles ça
n'a pas été repris et j'ai expliqué
pourquoi j'avais prononcé cette phrase
est ce qu'il y avait avant la phrase et
après la phrase mais daniel
schneidermann probablement reviendra là
dessus tout à l'heure mais c'est
extraordinaire avec la presse entre la
presse et des hommes politiques
il ya donc pas dire l'incompréhension
mais il y a une sorte de règle du jeu
est une des règles du jeu épouvantables
pour les hommes politiques m'ont soumis
aux politiques très tard végéter
ingénieurs pendant 15 ans j'ai découvert
ça un peu sur le tard j'ai appris au fur
et à mesure une chose terrible c'est que
vous pouvez faire un discours d'une
demi-heure pouvait dire des choses
passionnantes mais si à un moment donné
vous à une petite phrase du 10 secondes
qu'on arrache on sort du contexte
on voulait que le visage que l'on vous
la renvoie dix ans plus tard ou quinze
ans plus spécial que les journalistes
trouve passionnant par général salue
marie ça c'est leur problème mais je
sais qu'il pourrait se passionner pour
autre chose
et certains d'ailleurs se passionne
brocciu dans les six mois quand même
poursuivre la question qu'est ce qui
vous agace le plus con vous surnomme
revêt spam sur le mois
ça me rappelle alors quand je rappelle
aux gants donc qu'il est en rêve c'est
gentil ses jantes en mémoire en mémoire
de votre wii vous voyez vous voyez votre
échec aux municipales et 80 grammes
non pour mémoire de ma campagne pour les
deux langages je vais pas du tout pas du
tout le monde et moi ce qui m'agace
c'est qu'on déforme les gars c'est qu'on
déforme
dans le premier cas je vous expliquais
la déformation dans le deuxième cas et
je parle de vent 1 m en publicité
thierry ardisson ma campagne s'était pas
qu'il est andres c'était paris tendresse
paris qui laisse
et jamais eu qui laisse pendre s d'abord
ça me fait plaisir remarquer qu'on se
souvienne de sa puissance pas pour
gommer un peu rebelle spl qui reste en
bresse on peut c'est parce que ça
correspond à mon tempérament profond
avant qu'ils veulent harvest père tente
également je suis fier c'est une
plaisanterie de mauvais goût
le goût si c'est une chose qui se
partagent pas bien hall qui laissera
passer l'astre audio maintenant c'est à
dire que notre match de services michael
del mar à partir de votre heure de
naissance votre date de naissance votre
lieu de naissance à étudier un peu dans
les astres est d'abord votre avenir
politique alors est ce que paul quilès
un avenir politique alors est-ce qu'il
doit retourner dans les pétrole ou
diriger un journal je suis considéré
d'abord de se méfier en imagination qui
me touche que quelques points du slogan
publicitaire à double tranchant
origination ou vérité cialis notre
publicité seule imagination des phrases
lapidaires d'eovi raconte une question
sont quelquefois qui font tourner contre
vous je crois tu penses pas qu'il peut
redevenir ministre ou un truc comme ça
non j'ai pas l'impression je ne pense
pas de toute manière que la politique
soit vraiment votre terrain de
prédilection
vous êtes un venus bien vous êtes
davantage fait pour les arts pour une
une communication plus plus harmonieuse
via nos savoirs il est fort il a lu
une réserve que vous n'êtes pas
réellement fait qu'on a positive les
tons purs profit des analystes qu'est ce
que c'est un compliment
oui dites pas ça tous les abrutis non
maintenant on a parlé tout à l'heure de
la gaffe de valence on a parlé
la mairie de paris on a parlé du matin
de paris est ce que tu penses que c'est
ce qu'il faut bien appeler des échecs
successifs sont inscrits dans le thème
astral de paul quilès en fait je pense
que déjà deux points de vue pratique
vous devriez éviter mais années impaires
oui c'est moi réussit facilement ont
chacune sur deux oui voilà la question
de mathématiciens qui à 88 ses pertes et
d'autre part depuis quelques années vous
êtes vous vivez sur le carré de pluton
et c'est une métamorphose profonde que
vous présenterez d'opérer je pense que
vous êtes en train de vous tourner vers
autre chose que la politique ou tout
venir c'est vrai je me tourne mais
meilleur du pire d'activer faut avouer
je tourne la tête gelé dans le dos j'ai
fait des chèques sont pour vous le signe
qu'il faut peut être chercher quelque
chose d'autre avant ou utilisés par les
astres quoi s'évader quoi le piano mais
les arts du blizzard de manière générale
oui à mal en passant la vie sentimentale
comme qui laisse à de très beaux lésés
par les succès aussi parce que la
description du passé
mais normal exhaustive oui non les
sucres et fonds inscrit à mon avis dans
un avenir plutôt vénitien fallait
retourner vers veut faire le
d'expression artistique alors maintenant
vous avez été ministre de la défense on
va voir un sujet qui a été tourné dans
votre ancien de vérité ou votre bureau
là attendez mal c'est dans la très bien
là on va regarder c'est un sujet sur les
canards du ministère parce qu'un canard
qui s'appelle qu'il est et oui rihanna
qui s'appelle hernu non non non non vous
voyez ce couple n'est pas eu son canard
non pourquoi se fera aussi l'objet de le
faire mal on vit alors
c'est à deux pas de l'assemblée
nationale derrière une petite grille
modeste que se trouve l'hôtel de brienne
et la bri les locaux du ministère de la
défense passe à un superbe parc peuplé
d'insolent kroes d'arbres centenaires
c'est très gaullien et de quelques
canards
il y avait les oies du capitole bain de
minuit est heureux de vous présenter les
canards de la république
vous pouvez me donner le nom de chacun
de ces canards bien monsieur beau je me
suis amusé
l'auteur du chat qui naissent et que
vous avez remarqué qui en est un des
quatre plus habiles à la plongée non pas
spécialement mon premier en 2004 les
doigts palmés ne voit pas le niveau le
plus pur pour la nage
d'accord ils perdent beaucoup le recul
c'est normal ce
c'est l'hiver les ont leur plumage
d'hiver lorsque l'hiver citerne eu perd
des plumes en ce moment c'est normal
c'est normal malgré l'impressionnant
déploiement de forces autour de leurs
passes 1 nos quatre canards ne reste pas
à l'abri des tracasseries de la vie
quotidienne ministériel le canard le
theule se réfugie dans la boulimie par
nostalgie des garden party de l'elysée
quant aux canards qui laisse il est
atteint d'une paranoïa de doute il faut
dire que son propriétaire n'a pas pris
de ses nouvelles depuis son départ de
l'hôtel de brienne le canard bourges
s'ennuie passant ses journées à dormir
depuis bientôt sept ans quant aux
canards hernu nous n'avons reçu que des
coups de bec en guise de réponse à notre
question innocente et donc tu es très
sociable il se bat jamais entre eux non
non non non je n'y ai regardé son rôle a
fait ils cohabitent siens y cohabitent
très bien 86 a trouvé un petit peu
agitée non non pas agiter faux documents
c'est pas qu'il s'agisse un petit peu
non pas spécialement
non pas spécialement pour eux la vie
continue finalement une pièce we can
assez calme paisible
ça c'est parce qu'ils ont le ventre
plein pour eux ça problème c'est
uniquement ça qui les intéresse
finalement remis uniquement il ya plein
d'autres choses non non non non non non
non sylvain 2010 au ministère de la
défense avoue bain de minuit
s'est passé comment le jour où vous avez
baptisé de canard le jour du départ on
m'a rappelé que d'une tradition toujours
eu toutes les traditions elle est drôle
celle là en tout cas qui consistait à ce
que le ministre au moment de son départ
à y apporter un nouveau canard dans la
mare hier je vais apporter cinq ou six
noms mon avis un peu moins et noir 4,5
et moi j'ai amené le mien je sais que
c'est assez bizarre de soutien canard
dans l'eau surtout celui là à l'évidence
ne voulais pas y aller
l'envoyé il ressortait à toute vitesse
et contrairement à ce qui est dit n'est
pas tout à fait visant à reporter n'est
pas allée jusqu'au fond de la de la
vérité on va les bureaux où l assemblée
donne sur la mare de l'autre côté je me
demande même si c'était pas trop mon
bureau le reportage et je vais je peux
voir donc l'état des canards et je
constate que le mien se porte bien et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu